one of my favorite ways to make content
is to talk about my favorite way rather
than say this is the best way and when
you say it that way you don't seem like
a dick because you're saying this is my
favorite way instead of saying how to
build a seven-figure agency you say how
I built a seven-figure agency the
difference is you're not projecting
anything onto anyone you're sharing what
you learned I'm sharing my favorite way
to get new customers I'm sharing my
favorite way to use outbound not the
three only ways or the three best ways
because those people will argue with you
on but if you say this is my favorite
what can they say and that allows you to
make way better content without getting
the hate